just when you think that the state of
California Gomorrah by the Sea cannot
become any more depraved we get a new
analysis from The Daily Mail which shows
that thousands of California pedophiles
have served less than a year in prison
this on the heels of that weird
Balenciaga child porn obscene kind of
campaign this obviously all in the age
of Jeffrey Epstein and creepypeto island
with all of the elite Rich prominent
people all over the world this new study
has found that more than seven thousand
child molesters were released within
months after Federal authorities
sentenced them to prison to put that in
perspective
the horn hat guy
got three and a half years for dancing
around the capitol pro-life Advocates
are currently facing 11 years in prison
for demonstrating outside of abortion
clinics
but pedos are getting off with less than
a year unless of course they hung out
with Jeffrey Epstein in which case
they've gotten off scot-free Justice in
America I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
Alice Siobhan what a great name Siobhan
I love that name who says as someone who
struggled with suicidal ideology for
over 10 years if I had seen that
Canadian ad glorifying suicide and heard
that when I was at my lowest I might
have succeeded rather than getting help
many such cases what's going on right
now in Canada is going to kill a lot of
people that's what assisted suicide is
and obviously by its very nature it's
always cloaked in the language of
compassion and helping people all it is
is killing people it's all it is is
giving into despair all it is is
pretty much the worst thing you can
possibly think of other than the pedo
stuff that's going on too I mean this is
this is really really dark stuff going
on in the so-called civilized West now
it's not all doom and gloom okay but we
do have to protect ourselves we got to
protect our country our civilization we
got to protect our homes that's why you
need ring the holidays are upon us and
many people are traveling I'm traveling
for speeches we're traveling to go see
family we are on the road okay
that is why you need ring I love ring
ring makes me feel much much safer with
ring security products you can rest easy
knowing that you're home and your family
are safe when you are not there the ring
video doorbell that notifies you when
you get guests when you get packages
absolutely fabulous Rings indoor cameras
allow you to keep an eye on the kids and
the pets while you are away ring alarm
will alert you when there is any motion
detection while the house is empty and
if you add ring smart lighting around
your home you can turn the lights on and
off while you're away which is extremely
handy Ring's home security products do
not just keep your home and family safe
they make perfect gifts for everyone on
the list I have not only received ring
products I have given ring products to
my friends because I really really love
ring and I want my friends and my family
to be safe as well and it's a really
good deal head on over to ring.com
collections slash offers to find out how
you can live a little more stress-free
this season with a ring product that is
right for you
that is ring.com
collections slash offers there is a
little glimmer of hope coming out of
even America's blue cities it seems like
everything in the blue cities is just
going from bad to worst to worse to
worse all the way down the slippery
slope and you've seen this in some of
the crime statistics and footage out of
Philadelphia or Los Angeles or Chicago
where
but if you look at New York right now
the Democrat mayor of New York Eric
Adams has you got to give credit where
credit's due
done something that actually will likely
improve the city
people with severe and untreated mental
illness who live out in the open on the
streets in our Subways in in danger and
in need
we see them every day
and our city workers are familiar with
their stories if severe mental illness
is causing someone to be unsheltered and
a danger to themselves we have a moral
obligation to help them get the
treatment and care they need we can no
longer deny the reality that untreated
psychosis can be a cruel and
all-consuming condition that often
requires involuntary intervention
supervise medical treatment and
long-term care
this is the right policy it could go
terribly wrong there are lots of Hazards
here but this is the right policy it is
not compassionate or just or
conservative to allow crazy people to
die in the street especially in cities
that get very cold in the winter now
what you're going to hear is I think a
legitimate concern which is hold on
we're giving the state power to just
grab you and put you in a place
involuntarily and start pumping you full
of drugs and and filling your head with
whatever they want to fill it with yes
that is a hazard
makes this whole thing especially people
who are civil Libertarians I don't know
I don't want to give the government that
power that that was one of the arguments
that led to the abolition of the insane
asylums in the first place in the middle
of the 20th century
it hasn't worked out there are so many
crazy people who we allow to live in New
York now I don't think mayor Adams is
doing this necessarily because he's just
had a sort of moral turn of of heart or
something like that I think probably
he's looking around saying man New York
is going to pot no one wants to ride the
Subways no one wants to go outside
things are looking pretty bad out there
we got to do something about the
homeless but that was that was the
reaction that Rudy Giuliani had in the
90s and he really did clean up New York
and it is not only good for the citizens
of New York the ordinary functioning
citizens of New York it's good for the
crazy people too
now the ideal situation
would be that families are stronger that
communities are stronger the churches
are stronger and that they can take
these people in but that doesn't always
work a lot of crazy people on the street
don't have any family left anymore or
they don't want to accept help from the
organizations that are offering them
services and that are powerless if the
if the crazy people don't want to go
we need the power
to involuntarily
commit crazy people for their own good
for our good for the common good and
this does not mean that we're now just
like the left if we're going to use
government power to do whatever no it
depends on what you're using government
power for if you're using government
power for good things within their
proper limits in their proper place
that's good if you're using government
power for bad things that's bad okay but
it is childish and morally blind to say
well because government power can be
used for a bad thing we're not going to
use it at all that is what has led
conservatives to be a completely useless
force in American politics and it's
What's led to this social breakdown that
we are seeing all around us so it's kind
of weird to say it I guess a stopped
clock is right twice a day good job
mayor Adams this is the right thing and
conservatives should take note
now speaking of New York back to dissing
New York and the lunatic left Wingers
that live there
it took them about a week
it took them longer actually than I
thought that it would
but but the New York Times has finally
managed to make the Balenciaga
child porn story and attack on
conservatives it's hard for them to do
that
obviously very hard but they're they're
Adept at it I mean think about
how quickly you had that Maniac
non-binary member of the LGBT community
shoot up a gay nightclub and that was
somehow conservative's fault you you had
all sorts of these stories that they
always managed to turn it on
conservatives this one they were having
trouble though because Balenciaga is
beloved by liberals the face of
Balenciaga is Kim Kardashian but so many
other left-wing celebrities as well
the the imagery was so overt it's
exactly the story of stuff conservatives
have been warning about for a long time
that the libs are peddling
pedophilia and Satanism and you just saw
it right there on display in the
Balenciaga photo shoot but but now that
the New York Times headline is not
Balenciaga pushes weird Kitty porn stuff
the the New York Times headline is when
high fashion and Q Anon collide
okay I'm gonna put a pause right there
I consider myself pretty with it you
know I'm pretty involved in conservative
politics I've gone down a lot of rabbit
Trails I have read a lot of content on
the far right on the far left I travel
around the country speaking to
conservatives everywhere
I still don't know what Q Anon is do you
do you know what Q Anon is I know it
it's something to do with
Elite pedos which is just true obviously
I think there's an island you know that
they all went to the Jeffries you know
but so I know it's something to do with
that but I don't I don't know the only
thing that I've really ever heard about
Q Anon is from MSNBC and CNN and the New
York Times I am not convinced that
anyone actually believes what Q Anon is
I'm fairly convinced it's just a fake
thing that the New York Times made up to
make right Wingers sound crazy because
what as far as I can tell the right
Wingers
look around at Jeffrey Epstein's Island
and they look around at the uh bizarre
Balenciaga photo shoot and they look
around and everything in the middle and
they look around at drag queen Story
Hour and they look around at trancing
the kids and they look around at the
child drag shows where the weird men are
putting dollars in the clothing of the
the little kids dancing around and we
look at that and we say hey you guys are
groomers you guys are sexualizing
children you guys have a bizarre sexual
interest in children and that's really
weird and you also have a lot of overt
satanic imagery there in the drag shows
and in the Balenciaga and all and hey
that's kind of weird and we should stop
that and then the libs
they come around and they say huh you
probably you crazy because you probably
believe in Q Anon you say well I don't
know what Q Anon is I definitely believe
in all that stuff I just said though
because I'm looking at it because I saw
it happen I'm looking at it right now in
the Balenciaga website it's like oh
you crazy conspiracy there you're
probably a q a I don't know what Q Anon
is I don't but I don't but I do know
that what I just said is true and is
happening there were court cases about
it it is for sure there's an island in
the Caribbean you CR it's just a way
it's just a way to pain conservatives as
lunatics
for observing what they were doing and
so what did the New York Times say it
says two new Balenciaga campaigns
ignited a firestorm that traveled from
the internet to Fox News fueled by
allegations
that the brand condoned child
exploitation those allegations you know
those crazy allegations after Balenciaga
portrayed little kids who looked sad and
in distress holding s m teddy bears and
then in another ad campaign included
references direct references to child
pornography you know it's just it's so
weird how it fueled all those crazy
rumors what crazy allegations that are
obvious and right before our very eyes
you know I've got an allegation to make
about this economy it's in chaos which
is why you got to check out gold gotta
check out Birch gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98. are you a little
down about the lack of a red wave in the
midterm elections you're a little
worried that maybe that lack of a Redway
will lead to even more Reckless spending
and inflation and economic chaos if
you're not sure how the next two years
are going to unfold or if you are sure
and you don't like the way things are
looking you gotta talk to Birch gold
group about protecting your savings with
gold Birch gold makes it easy to convert
your IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals so you can own gold and silver in
a tax sheltered account here's what you
need to do very very simple
you take out that phone you text Knowles
k o w l e s to 98 98 98 to claim your
free info kit on gold then talk to one
of their precious metals Specialists
they will hold your hand through the
entire process with an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers in almost
20 years of experience converting IRAs
and 401ks into precious metals IRAs
Birch gold can help protect your savings
too text Knowles to 98 98 98 protect
yourself with gold today that is nulls
text it to 98.98 98. yeah if you saw
balenciaga's child porn campaign if you
if you have noticed drag queen Story
Hour if you notice that these weirdos
are going in and having little kids
dress up in sexual costumes and dance
around at gay bars yeah you're you're
just an Internet troll
with crazy allegations according to the
New York Times then New York Times
writes
as online criticism of the campaign
spread the story was picked up across
right-wing media Outlets including the
New York Post and Prime Time Fox News
show Tucker Carlson tonight the show
helped to publicize in mainstream Q Anon
whatever that is the the internet
conspiracy theory that a group of Satan
worshiping Elites who run a child sex
ring are trying to control our politics
and media oh that's what Q Anon is okay
well if that's what Q Anon is then it's
just obviously true okay because I
haven't seen the whole Jeffrey Epstein
client book because the U.S government's
covering it up and the US government is
not holding any of those pedophiles to
account and the US government gave a
sweetheart deal to Jeffrey Epstein
himself before he got Epstein they gave
him a really sweetheart deal and they
let him live in what was essentially a
condo in Palm Beach that they called it
a local jail
and when the U.S attorney Alex Acosta
asked about it he was told don't touch
Jeffrey Epstein he belongs to
intelligence and I know that he was
paddling around with the most elite
prominent wealthy people all over the
world and there were trafficking very
very young girls to have sex with I know
that I know that for sure so what's the
part that isn't real
because I'm just talking about that one
the one aspect of what you're telling me
you're telling me that's what Q Anon is
well if that's what Q Anon is
I've I have seen that reported in the
New York Times okay because even the New
York Times eventually had to report on
the Jeffrey Epstein story I've seen I've
seen the evidence for that
and I'm still seeing the cover-up of
that
and I'm still seeing weird child sex
stuff all around the culture that you
guys are promoting that the New York
Times is promoting in schools
in these drag shows in libraries
and I'm still seeing a defense of the
completely indefensible Balenciaga
campaign what's so amazing is the libs
haven't gotten their messaging straight
on this because the New York Times
argument here is this Balenciaga thing
is a total non-traversing crazy
conspiracy theory being pushed by poker
Carlson and it's nothing and it's wild
and
but what did Balenciaga say
Balenciaga said this is completely
unacceptable we're so sorry Balenciaga
wiped its Instagram account except for
the apology valenciaga said that it is
pursuing legal action against the people
who put the photo shoot together
so which is it
no big deal nothing Burger nothing to
see here as is the New York Times this
is extremely serious we're going to wipe
out all of our our branding away we're
gonna get rid of this photo shoot and
we're going to sue people into Oblivion
for doing it which is it
obviously it's the latter very fact that
the New York Times keeps covering up for
this
well it's not going to dispel any
conspiracy theories let's let's just put
it that way not at all speaking of
uh weird sex stuff
the Republicans voted last night
to abolish marriage
to effectively abolish marriage
and to punish anyone who objects to the
abolition of marriage they did this
through the so-called respect for
Marriage Act this has been a slow
rolling disaster it already started a
couple of weeks ago when the Republican
Senators to voted to allow this thing to
get past the filibuster so that the
Democrats would only need a bare
majority instead of 60 votes to get this
bill through the bill would enshrine the
legal definition of marriage that you
saw in a burgerfeld that marriage is no
longer a union between one man and one
woman for the good of the spouses and
the sake of the generation of Education
the children as people who thought we're
all with human history but now marriage
is
two people of any sex
for whatever purpose it's vaguely
romantic but it doesn't have to be and
anyway that's what it is for now that's
the the new view obviously this view is
opposed by uh
Christians Jews Muslims reasonable
agnostics in the natural law but that's
that was the view Advanced by the
Supreme Court at least for a while you
had conservatives opposing this madness
again it's not no knock on gay guys it's
no attack we've all everyone's got gay
friends no it's not an attack on any
person it's just an acknowledgment of
reality acknowledgment that if marriage
does not have at its core sexual
difference then it just doesn't mean
anything you you really can't Define it
it lose it loses its Essence it the
marriage loses its marriageness if if it
loses that fundamental aspect of it and
so at least you had the conservative
sort of kind of putting up a fight well
that's that's over because these
Republican Senators was it Roy blunt
Richard Burr Shelly more capito Susan
Collins Todd young Joni Ernst Cynthia
Lamas that one's frustrating because I
kind of like Cynthia Lamas uh Lisa
murkowski Rob Portman Mitt Romney Dan
Sullivan and Tom Tillis these guys all
voted for it uh
they and and not only do they vote for
it not only did you first have those 12
Republican Senators who voted to set it
on a fast track to being passed but then
you had certain Republicans at the last
minute who were filing amendments to say
okay look you're going to redefine
marriage you're gonna you're gonna
completely swish to the Democrats you're
not going to conserve a damn thing if
you're not going to conserve the
fundamental institution but please at
the very least can you include some
protections for people who object to the
new definition can you include some
protections for the many many Christians
Jews Muslims who don't want to have to
be forced to participate in a gay
marriage like like quote unquote gay
marriage like like Jack Phillips at
masterpiece cake shop who the LGBT
gestapo have hounded for years and have
destroyed this man's life and they take
him to court even when he wins in court
they drag him to court again because
it's not enough merely to be tolerated
or accepted this this political campaign
is forcing the anyone who objects anyone
who holds a traditional and sensible
view to comply
and to participate and to actively
constantly affirm what is utterly
incoherent and so you had people like
Mike Lee most notably but a couple other
people Marco Rubio and there was one
other who filed amendments to say hey
just can you at least protect the
religious people here who want to follow
their conscience and reason
what happened the Democrats of course
said no no we're not protecting those
religious business owners
but the Republicans said that too that
Mitt Romney's said that too it's just
pathetic and I look at that
I know we've got the senate race in
Georgia doesn't matter because the
Democrats control the Senate
so yeah I'd like Herschel to win I guess
I'd like Republicans to control the
Senate I guess but
what do I care what do I really care
these guys
not only can't conserve anything they
don't want to conserve anything their
political views are just fundamentally
wrong okay they are to the left of
Barack Obama in 2011. what do I care
oh we've got we have this is the most
important election in our lifetimes we
we have to elect Republicans because
if we don't elect Republicans then
they're not going to be able to vote for
the Democrat marriage bill
and and then we're not going to be able
to say that Democrats are the real
transphobes or whatever I don't know if
we don't elect Republicans then only the
Democrats are going to pass the Democrat
agenda but if we elect Republicans then
the Republicans will also pass the
Democrat agenda and that's why it's the
most important election in our lifetimes
I don't think so I mean these people
should be primary obviously
but
I I just I don't even see the point if
any of these people came up to me and
said we Michael I need your vote I'd say
okay for what
why do you need my vote
to do what
to do what the Democrats want
more radically than they asked for 10
years ago no thanks no thank you don't
think we need that speaking of
certain sexual practices the World
Health Organization has just come out
there they've got a new strong stance on
monkey pox and they're really going to
do something about monkey well no
they're not they're not going to do
anything about monkey pox but they are
going to change the name of monkey pox
so they're not really going to help
people who have monkey pox and they're
not really going to do anything to stop
the spread of monkey pox but they are
this is really crucial going to change
the name of it because the name you see
is apparently very offensive
uh quote in seven in several rather
meetings public and private a number of
individuals and countries have raised
concerns and asked the who to propose a
way forward to change the name because
you see the the name of monkey boxes is
offensive it's stigmatizing
and so uh we we need to change it
they're suggesting M pox okay much
problem solved good job guys
did it ever occur to The Who
that instead of
spending all their time focused on how
we talk about monkey pox
we could maybe
change the behavior that causes monkey
box monkey box is caused by gay orgies
that's what causes it outside of Zaire
the way you get monkey pox is by going
to gay origin not even just
sex with one gay guy and you only have
sex with that gay guy you go to gay
Origins you the way you get it
statistically is by having sex with guys
who have sex with lots and lots of other
guys the who could very easily say hey
fellas cut it out
don't do that that's not good that's
going to be bad for you but they could
you imagine if the who said that oh my
goodness the reaction there would be
calls for resignations
so instead they don't do anything to
stop it's just like the Coronavirus it's
the coronavirus the way to stop the
coronavirus is to stop fronting gain of
function research and stop funding the
Wuhan Institute of virology and stop
conducting this weird research that most
likely it seems led to the outbreak of
the virus no no no we're not going to do
any of that we're going to actually keep
funding that research but hey we're
going to call it covid we're going to
call it Delta Lambda whatever we're
going to change the name we're not going
to change any of the behavior that that
causes these things to break out
we're going to continue to play stupid
games
and we are going to continue to win
stupid prizes now for me that that tells
me I've need I gotta work on myself okay
I need to be healthy I don't want to get
these these crazy kinds of diseases
flying around I want to be in good
health I want my iron levels to be up I
want to be big and Burly and strong I
need good red meat I need
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use code Knolls I just
absolutely love these guys good ranchers
I love the people that are involved I
love the way they conduct their business
and most of all I love the meat it is
such high quality and I am something of
a meat Aficionado I don't go vegetarian
for very many meals ever okay and I've
had other meat subscription services and
I've obviously bought made a lot of
butchers these guys have top top Quality
Meat and in most places it's getting
more expensive and during due to a
shrinking herd beef prices are expected
to rise another 15 in 2023. the place
where meat prices are not Rising
incredibly is good Ranchers right now
good ranchers will inflation proof your
grocery bill by locking in your price
for the life of your meat subscription
you don't need to get a meat
subscription you just order the meat but
if you get the subscription it's just
unbelievable you're going to lock in
that price that's not enough to convince
you you can take advantage of their
Black Friday offer right now get two 12
ounce Black Angus New York strip steaks
and two pasture-raised chicken breasts
free with any order when you use code
nulls that's goodranchors.com use code
Knolls for the special offer two Black
Angus New York strip steaks and pasture
raised chicken breasts free with your
order goodranchers.com code Knowles good
ranchers American Meat delivered so
you've got this huge push right now from
the liberal establishment and it's it's
a bigger push
than even than usual you've got the New
York Times blaming conservatives for
Balenciaga child pornography shoots
right that's pretty outrageous you've
got the Republicans advancing a radical
marriage law far to the left of Barack
Obama in 2011.
you've got
you've got the World Health Organization
saying don't worry about what actually
causes any sorts of diseases or
epidemics just we just have to change
the name that's all that really matters
and now
the cherry on top probably the most
ridiculous least believable part of all
of this
Don Lemon is insisting that CNN
has never been liberal press like he's
the he's the CEO of CNN he's your boss
now he's just he's to stand right over
there he's standing right over there and
hit the Applause sign right forward to
commercial basically all his job was and
now he's got a really hard job which is
which is running a CNN the word on the
street is that you guys aren't allowed
to be liberal anymore is that is that
the case I don't think we ever were
liberal what yes I don't think we've
ever worked not me saying that that's
the people out there saying that he's
not letting you be liberal anymore well
I listen I think that I think what Chris
is
saying is that he wants Republicans
sensible Republicans he wants us to hold
people to account but he wants people to
come on and feel comfortable with coming
on and talking on on CNN and appearing
on CNN so if you invite someone in your
house you want to make them comfortable
but also but by the nature of what we do
we have to hold people to account and so
that doesn't necessarily mean that we're
going liberal or conservative or
whatever it just means that we are doing
what we do and that's good journalism
that is not true that has never been
true
forget even what Don Lemon said about
CNN I don't I don't think we're liberal
obviously that's not true obviously
that's lying in gaslighting but even the
broader point that Don Lemon is making
about journalism look we just hold
people to account okay we've got that's
part of our job that's what we do we
hold people to account we speak truth to
power
that is not true
CNN has never done that
listen we've just got to be objective
we're not right or left we're not
liberal or conservative that's what
journalists are we're not we're just
objective that is not true that has
never been true not just that's that's
not just the case with CNN that's the
case with all of Journalism the idea of
the objective journalist who speaks
truth to power is a complete fantasy
that has never existed in the history of
the world okay
journalism is when powerful interests
seek to get their message out
that's what journalism is and
occasionally it's when not so powerful
interests like individuals with an
agenda with a perspective on the world
try to get their message out too that
would be independent journalists or
alternative journalism or citizen
journalism
but it all has an agenda
journalism is always a mouthpiece for a
particular world view
there is no such thing as objective
journalism there can't be any such thing
as objective journalism because that
would imply that one can be neutral
about public affairs
while advancing a narrative about public
affairs it is not possible there is no
neutrality and it's not just that oh
well too bad we can't go back to the
good old days of the neutral Public
Square that has never existed that was
just made up and it was basically a
psyop by the liberal establishment after
World War II to to establish what what
we now call everyone calls the left and
the right the liberal consensus
and then some conservatives came in and
poked around at that and broke it down a
little bit and exposed the lie and the
Sham that that was
so it was so offensive about this I mean
look maybe Don Lemon is just ignorant
could be and I don't want to ascribe to
malice that which is explained by
ignorance and stupidity
but I I don't think he's
stupid I think he's a relatively
intelligent guy and he's been very
malleable over the years when CNN has
wanted him to be a little bit more
moderate he's been more moderate when
CNN has wanted him to be far left he's
been far left so he clearly
is able to adapt
but for for him to say
we journalists we speak truth power
we're objective
it's just such gaslighting that's not
what it is okay
and it nor should it be that people
should not just be blank automatons that
view everything equally people should
not put Good and Evil on the same on the
same level people should not put truth
and falsehood on the same level people
should not put Beauty and ugliness on
the same level no yeah you've got to
pick a side of course you have to have a
perspective if you articulate any view
of anything you were taking aside you're
you're having a perspective
and unfortunately I think it was
conservatives who who kind of bought the
myth maybe the Liberals believe their
own nonsense but conservatives bought
into it too there are many conservatives
who say oh you know I just kind of
missed the days of Walter Cronkite we
could all trust Walter Cronkite no we
couldn't the man was a leftist and a
member of the world world Federalist
Society the man lost the Vietnam War
okay give me a break all right oh yes
neutral Walter Cronkite he was very far
on the left oh we just used to have
neutrality
no we did not speaking of liberal things
I have to get to this I talked about it
a little bit yesterday in the member
block but
had to get to this for the
for the main show
the U.S soccer team won the game against
Iran
and I I don't know how I'm supposed to
feel about this I don't I I heard the
news I was giving a speech last night at
Franciscan University of Steubenville
really great to be here in Steubenville
Ohio Franciscan is a fabulous school we
had a sold out standing room only room
and we talked about how science is fake
and you can catch the the lecture on
YouTube right now at the yaf YouTube
channel but during the Q a someone asked
me why I don't like soccer and I said I
don't even know what happened in this
game and someone told me said Michael
America won
and I was crestfallen
not because I don't want to root for the
home team not because I like Iran
but it's just
ugh I just I don't like that America is
in the World Cup
I think it would be much better for
America look I think it would be much
better for the soccer players if they
finally went home you know if their
mothers came up in the minivan and
picked them up and gave them a little
snack and drove them home so they could
go back to their school work or whatever
they do but and I think it would be good
for the country as a whole if we stopped
participating in soccer because it
it just seems so try hard
the only people I I can tell who pretend
to like soccer in America are the sort
of people who want to seem really
sophisticated and Cosmopolitan and
European and it's just
cut it out guys
it's weird no one really it's it's
the other problem with soccer is that
it's so new
it has no history in America and it
doesn't have that much history period
soccer only goes back to the middle of
the 19th century and so you know the
soccer U.S soccer team won
and I feel very ambivalent about that
and I realize though that the
ambivalence that a lot of people feel
about U.S soccer
reflects the ambivalence that a lot of
people feel about U.S foreign policy
it occurred to me there's actually a
political Point here there's a lot of
conservatives are like ah you know okay
all right we're playing the game we go
go all right go beat Iran and whatever
and you know
but we don't feel that strong we don't
feel that enthusiastic about it
and it's kind of the same with foreign
policy
you know a lot of conservatives had
turned on the wars in the Middle East by
the time that we finally got out of
there so Joe Biden bungled it was a
complete disaster but there were a lot
of conservatives who were happy that we
got out of Afghanistan because they were
asking the question what are we doing
there
what is the purpose of us in Afghanistan
is it's not to exactly to conquer the
country
it's not to impose American government
on the country we had a kind of puppet
regime I guess but it wasn't
we didn't really claim it as our own
and we were we were instilling our
values in Afghanistan but what were
those values
Pride flags and tranzing the kids and
feminism and what what are the because a
lot of conservatives were looking at I
say hold on if those are the values that
we're spreading overseas then I don't
really want to be overseas I don't
really want to be Conquering the world
if Conquering the world means that we're
going to raise the rainbow flag in
Kandahar
it's the same kind of ambivalence all
right we're gonna go beat let the people
at the soccer game at the super lib
thing I don't think so
I don't
we have to
we have to deal with this domestic
crisis in America
that we
speak two languages that we have two
different
systems of morals that we and and not
just
we disagree here and there on certain
issues like we fundamentally view the
human person in the nation in radically
different ways okay we have to deal with
that issue if we want to under if we
want to make sense of our foreign policy
what we're doing abroad and if we want
to make sense of our Sports and our
games and our Recreation games and
sports have always had a patriotic
element to it that that goes back to
ancient Greece and the Olympics it
remains true today
what is that patriotic element what does
the U.S stand for until we answer that
question at home we're not going to make
a lot of sense of what we're doing
abroad whether it's in Qatar on the
football field or whether it's in
Afghanistan with the pride flag
speaking of corruption in our political
system
bad news out of Arizona
Maricopa County
has certified the vote in that
bizarre Shenanigans filled election for
the midterms the Integrity of my
colleagues up here on the diocese in the
Integrity of Stephen richer were
questioned over and over and over again
and I know this is not my seat this is
the people's seat that I sit in and one
day I won't sit in this seat but while
I'm sitting here I'm going to defend the
Integrity of these five men you can
think what you want to about me but
these are good men who are in public
service for the right reasons and I am
proud to serve with every single one of
them
again this was not a perfect election
but it was safe and secure the votes
have been counted accurately and I thank
everyone for their attention today and
with that I would entertain a motion
totally safe and secure counted totally
accurately how dare you even even
question that this is a really important
step in the Democratic process and yes
lots of voting machines didn't work and
yes lots of people were made to wait for
a very long time and yes people were
made to put their ballots in little
provisional boxes and yes according to
poll workers no one checked to see if
those ballot boxes were stuffed before
anyone put their ballots in them and yes
the poll workers observed that there
were exactly 200 ballots in some cases
that that were found in addition to
number of Voters who checked in that day
and yes it took the election officials a
week now more than a week to count the
votes and yes it's true that even the
Republican election officials who were
running things in Maricopa County were
validly opposed to trump-backed Maga
candidates and yes and obviously the
Democrats were opposed to them and yes
there were election problems last time
in Arizona too and yeah but hey
democracy prevails huh
I don't think so really really sad stuff
which is why I'm very pleased
that Kerry lake is suing Maricopa County
she really stands up firm okay she that
woman she is
she's got some masculine qualities to
her okay she's still a woman though she
doesn't use Jeremy's razors you should
go check out Jeremy's razors today just
in time for the holidays Jeremy's razors
has launched a new razor that would be
the all-new Precision 5 razor with a
flip back trimmer it's got five blades
making it the perfect tool to hone your
hairlines and refine your look Precision
five blades fit in the original Founders
series handle there you have it it's so
so beautiful so if you already bought a
Jeremy's razor and you want the new
Precision five blades as I can highly
recommend look at this baby face over
here you can do that by going to the
website and visiting the new
self-service portal Jeremy's razors is
more than just shaving now too head on
over to jeremy'srazors.com to kick woke
companies out of your bathroom get 30
percent off all Jeremy's products that
is jeremy'sraisers.com
Carrie lake is suing Maricopa County
Cary lake is not going quietly after
this election with all sorts of problems
in a place that has had all sorts of
problems for a number of years now she's
not just going to go quietly she says
quote filing today is basically just a
way for the courts to pressure Maricopa
County into giving us public records
that we've been asking for she blasted
the county officials over the treatment
of the election day workers including
the printer issues and the provisional
boxes and the three-hour lines she says
we cannot allow an election like this to
stand
I love it I love it I think she's
terrific I think that's great that's
exactly what Republicans should do Which
Way Western man Kerry lake or Mitt
Romney
the the comparison is apt because
they're both facing what they consider
to be lost causes
Carrie lake is facing the Lost Cause of
hey look there the counties are
certifying the votes the former
Secretary of State Katie Hobbs is going
to be the next governor of Arizona it's
so stop fighting just go just be polite
just say oh we lost but we lost with
dignity Eagle Way forget about all the
election problems in Maricopa Arizona
she's facing that logicals and then Mitt
Romney is facing the Lost Cause of
marriage he's saying look marriage we're
going to redefine marriage he says look
well I personally I personally believe
that marriage is what it has always been
for all of human history until five
minutes ago but I'm not going to impose
that view on other people and I'm a
really good guy and I love them
Democrats love me I'm Mitt Romney got to
work on my Romney impression promise
what I do admit Romney impression it
often sounds like Ronald Reagan I don't
I don't want to make that comparison but
but that's what Mitt Romney is looking
at
and so he he is trying to lose with
dignity he doesn't have any dignity
doing it but he wants to lose in this
really really respectable way you know
where he well I'm the I'm the opposition
but you I guess you guys bested us so
okay
we'll just we'll abolish the fundamental
political institution
so pathetic he's saying look we're gonna
lose but I want to Curry a little bit of
favor with the libs before we lose and
Carrie like is saying we're probably
going to lose but I'm going to go down
swinging okay and I I will take a carry
leg over a Mitt Romney approach any day
of the week I'm not convinced that we're
going to go down
if we are going to go down I want to go
down swinging but I'm not convinced
we're going to go down every time I make
any perfectly ordinary Common Sense
political observation people will say
they often say it on the marriage issue
they'll say Michael is this the hill you
want to die on
uh no I I don't intend to die on any
Hills
no I'm not setting out to die anywhere I
mean I will die at some point you know
no one here gets out alive but
I don't I'm not seeking help but I'm
I am going to say true things I am going
to muster I hope even on iota of courage
to stand up for those true things and if
you get me you get me but I don't think
you're going to get me I think most
people are normal and get it okay I
think most people have common sense
I don't think that the perverse weirdos
who who have disproportionate power in
our country I don't think the you know
the the fauces and the Claus Schwabs and
the Balenciaga and the New York Times
and all the rest I don't think I don't
think those guys have any common sense
but I think most people do and so yeah
we're gonna stand firm and we're going
to go down swinging if we have to go
down which I don't necessarily think
that we will speaking of women fighting
back
forget about Carrie Lake for a second
there is a woman an inspiration to us
all she's suing craft
you know the makers of the mac and
cheese she is suing craft for five
million dollars and she is suing them
because Velveeta ready Mac takes more
than three and a half minutes to cook
if you've ever purchased a delicious
Velveeta ready Mac you'll know it says
eat your ready Mac in only three and a
half minutes but this woman has found
out it actually takes more than that
because you got to open the package and
you've got to pour the water in then you
put it in the microwave then you let it
sit a little bit then you put the the
powder in and then you stir it you maybe
let it cool a little bit so
it takes I don't know four minutes or
something but it's it's more and so
she's suing craft for five million
dollars over this
the uh the lawyer who is bringing this
case said look I know some people think
it's frivolous but this is false
advertising okay we've got to go we're
going to take them to court
this does remind me of one of the most
famous lines in all of Shakespeare's
plays this comes from Henry VI Part Two
and the line is
they're being asked how to how to you
know have a good country is kind of what
they're describing what would they do to
change the political system and the line
from Shakespeare is
the first thing we do let's kill all the
lawyers
right line
probably would do us a lot of good as
well obviously it's a frivolous lawsuit
I don't I don't really care it's kind of
funny I assume it's going to be laughed
out of court but the problem with these
frivolous lawsuits and are extremely
litigious culture where you know
everything is so
legalistic
is that it actually does deprive us of
our common sense it actually does
deprive us of our ability to have a good
normal society
what you're seeing here with this absurd
litigious culture is is really just an
expression of what you're seeing in the
debate over what is a woman
it's this obtuse
uh pedantic legalistic kind of uh
frivolous argumentation over things that
we all know to be true we all know that
when you buy the Velveeta package it
says get your Velveeta in three and a
half minutes and then it takes four
minutes we all know that's just what
happens it's fine it's not a big deal we
all know what a woman is
but the culture well was it three and
three quarters minutes all right give me
his well is a woman what is a woman what
if someone has One X chromosome what if
someone has some ambiguity what if
someone's infertile is that you know
what a woman is it's it's the same
argumentation when it comes to
pornography
the argument against enforcing our laws
against porn and obscenity is well how
do you know what pornography is I don't
know you just do
we all just do about that when Justice
Potter Stewart famously infamously I
guess to to many people
replied when he was asked to define
marriage and said or define marriage
these days we can't even do that when he
replied uh in to a definition of
obscenity and he said I can't quite
Define it but I know it when I see it
everyone makes fun of him and says this
is so ridiculous that's true
of course we know when we see it we have
faculties of reason we have moral
conscience we we basically know the
difference between true and false and
good and bad and beautiful and ugly
but hyper-legalistic cultures
are are away away from that Common Sense
okay they blind us to that common sense
and and uh I don't know I want to get
back to a regular country where we do in
fact know it when we see it one of the
issues is that we no longer even as
we're arguing over these little
nitty-gritty words
our understanding of those words breaks
down that's that's the additional
problem here as we refuse to take
certain basic things for granted anymore
and we start squabbling over the meaning
of these words
as a part of that process we lose our
common language to the point that now we
actually don't really know what a woman
is to the point that never or we at
least convince ourselves of that we
don't really know what marriage is or we
at least convince ourselves of that
okay we're going to be arguing over all
of this until we're all just babbling
incoherently which I think we already
sort of are speaking of babbling
incoherently a place where a lot of that
takes place would be Twitter and there's
good news out of Twitter and it's good
news that didn't even make the news at
least not for a while
Twitter has stopped enforcing its covid
misinformation policy misinformation
policy also known as when you post true
information about covid and the vaccines
and the origins and Dr fauci on Twitter
and then Twitter says this is
misinformation and it was a really
really big deal and you could lose your
account and you'd be dinged and you'd be
suppressed
well all that went away
and what makes it newsworthy is it went
away
without Elon Musk even telling us that
it was going away
it he just quietly
got rid of it
now some people have noticed and so
they're saying yes it's true effective
November 23rd Twitter is no longer
enforcing it's covet misleading
information policy
this is how it's done
this is how it's done
the way that we were able to get rid of
the covid misinformation policy
was not through those loser Republican
Senators I don't mean to be too harsh
obviously there are a lot of great
Republican Senators Ted Cruz Mike Lee
Josh Hawley I mean there are many many
who are good but it's not those losers
who just can't muster a republican
majority
uh it's not it's not really them it's
not through some big campaign out in the
public it's just
we just won a rich guy over to our side
and then he started wielding power for
us
and I know a lot of people don't really
like that
but that's effective as it's been sort
of a theme of this week money talks and
Bs walks and Big Daddy Elon comes in and
he says yeah we're just not going to do
that anymore Twitter is my Play thing
now and we're not going to censor people
for saying true things about kovid and
Dr fauci and the vaccines and all the
rest of it and then he just does it
and the libs can whine and scream about
it but they don't have the power this is
this is really the culmination of a
movement you've been seeing on the right
for pro seven or eight years now which
is a movement away from the idea that
wielding power is bad this hyper
individualist idea don't you know don't
wield any power we don't want to be
authoritarians or whatever and a
movement toward no we obviously have to
wield power we've got very powerful
people wielding that power against us we
need to wield our power too good lesson
I want to see a lot more Elon musk's
okay want to see a lot more elons want
to see a lot more of the handful of
Republican Senators pushing back let's
do it baby let's do stuff or you deserve
to lose your seat and you should have
very little role in public life
all right we need we need to be let out
of our present bondage okay and when you
want and I'm not talking about bondage
like the Balenciaga thing I'm talking
about you know bondage like slavery okay
and when we want to watch a fabulous
show about
one of the all-time great narratives of
being led out of bondage you've got to
check out
Exodus Exodus with
Dr Jordan B Peterson last Friday we
released the first two episodes of the
brand new biblical series by Jordan that
is Exodus this follows up on his Genesis
series which was
one of if not the most popular piece of
content Jordan ever put out now we've
got this amazing Exodus series with
people like Dennis Prager Jonathan
peggio many many more new episodes
releasing weekly you do not want to miss
it check out the trailer
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
oh
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny I want villains to get
punished but do you want the villains to
learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question
I love Dennis so much I don't know all
those guys are absolutely fabulous the
series is really great you should go
check it out and to do that you got to
become a daily wire member the other
reason you got to become a daily wire
member that is how you join our little
Inner Circle here okay that is how you
join the member block that is not for
you Hoy polloi out there just in The
Ether okay that is for the creme de La
Creme who show up to the Daily wire
member section I feel I feel distant
from the daily wire remember block right
now because I'm on the road I'm in the
middle of nowhere in Ohio and so today
we will be discussing
all manner of things intimately directly
with our daily wire members if you want
to become one head on over right now
the show continues now we see at the
member block
[Music]
[Music]